in the previous videos in this series
we've seen that substrate structure is
the most important factor in determining
if a reaction will proceed by
substitution or elimination and if it'll
be sn1 sn2 e1 or e2 the nucleophile also
plays a big role so in this video we're
going to look at the different substrate
structures we can have look at the
different strengths of nucleophiles and
create a chart that'll allow us to
predict substitution or elimination
mechanisms we can have a poor
nucleophile examples of these are water
alcohols and acetic acid these
nucleophiles are poor they don't have a
lot of negative charge built up on them
we can also have weakly basic
nucleophiles
examples include cyanide the halogens
and anionic sulfur compounds our
nucleophile could also be a strong base
examples are oxygen and nitrogen
centered anions like hydroxide methoxide
or sodium amid the final category we'll
consider our strong bases that are quite
hindered the most common of these is
potassium or sodium tert-butoxide and
another example is LD a lithium
diisopropyl a m''d on this chart the
lithium or potassium counter ions are
not shown the simplest substrate with a
leaving group that we can have is methyl
X will represent our leaving group
whether it's bromo chloro otis 'l any of
our our good leaving groups on here one
thing to note right away about the
methyl substrate is that elimination is
not available to the substrate when we
do elimination we're forming a
carbon-carbon double bond this substrate
only contains one carbon so the only
mechanism that's available to us is
substitution this substrate cannot
ionize to form a carbo cation it'd be
very very unstable
now with poor nucleophiles this
substrate does not react very well at
all for our purposes we're going to say
that it has no reaction the reaction is
incredibly slow
now with the rest of these nucleophiles
the methyl substrate will react since it
can't form a carbo cation the only
mechanism available is sn2 even with
these hindered nucleophiles this is
really very unhindered so we're going to
form a bond next let's consider a
primary substrate that is unhindered
primary substrates don't tend to react
very well with these poor nucleophiles
either so will predict no reaction for
this first row again now primary carbo
cations are not stable either so with
weak bases we're going to get sn2 again
now being unhindered like this even with
a strong base we're going to get
substitution here in fact if X is a
halide and low R is say sodium methoxide
that's the Williamson ether synthesis
reaction now it's only when we use a
strong hindered base that attack right
here in an sn2 fashion is not as
possible we're going to have steric
hindrance from the bulkiness of the base
and so when we treat this substrate with
a strong hindered base we get
elimination again carbo cations primary
carbo cations are not stable so this
elimination will be an e2 mechanism now
let's consider a hindered primary
substrate so we have a little bit of
branching over here this is still a
primary substrate so with a poor
nucleophile we're going to again expect
no reaction and again with our weakly
basic nucleophiles we'll expect
sn2 now these strong bases are not going
to have as easy access to this carbon to
kick off the leaving group in an sn2
fashion like they do with the unbranched
primary so here we'll see when we start
using strong base and strong hindered
base we're going to promote e to
eliminations with the substrate of
course it's e to because we're still
dealing with a primary substrate primary
carbo cations are not stable let's move
on to secondary substrates now now we're
getting into the realm of where stable
carbo cation
and conform so when we have a poor
nucleophile which you should notice is
actually also a polar protic solvent
acetic acid water alcohols this is when
we're going to start getting some sn1
reactions going on the nucleophile isn't
strong it doesn't have a lot of pushing
power to push out this group in an sn2
fashion so under these conditions we'll
just wait around for this to ionize and
then the weak nucleophile can add now
whenever we're able to form a carbo
cation elimination is going to compete
so under these conditions we'll expect
to get some elimination by the e1
mechanism as well now we add some
negative charge a little bit more
pushing power into our nucleophile and
the main mechanism when we treat these
with a weak base our secondary
substrates is going to be sn2 now if we
compare our secondary substrate to our
primary hindered substrate we see we
have a similar type of branching over
here that branching is going to
sterically hindered
at the leaving group but the adjacent
protons are quite available and so
strong bases are going to promote
elimination these are really good
nucleophiles and they're going to push
our leaving group out by an e2 mechanism
in both our strong base and strong
hindered base situations onto our
tertiary substrates in order for an sn2
reaction to happen we need to get
backside attack of the nucleophile
displacing the leaving group tertiary is
much too hindered for that to be
possible and so under our poor
nucleophile conditions we're going to
wait around for this to ionize and then
the poor nucleophile can add in and this
describes an sn1 mechanism again once we
form the carbo cation here it's pretty
easy to get elimination and so there's a
competing mechanism under these
conditions which is again II one weak
bases will also promote a mixture of sn1
and e1 products a
the strong base and strong hindered
based situations don't provide the polar
protic environment that we need for this
compound to ionize and so each of these
situations is going to promote
elimination again by the e2 mechanism
okay let's do a summary of the trends
we're starting to discover from this
chart all of our primary and our methyl
case they do not react well with weak
nucleophiles so we've this corner of our
chart which doesn't react once
substitution mechanisms become available
with primary substrates we're going to
get sn2 as the substrate becomes more
hindered e 2 becomes a factor and strong
hindered bases whenever possible promote
e 2 and that actually extends all the
way down into this corner of the chart
with our secondary and tertiary
substrates so that's a good general
trend to notice once we can form stable
secondary and tertiary carbo cations the
sn1 mechanism becomes a choice under
these polar protic conditions with these
weak nucleophiles the substrates going
to sit around until it ionizes and then
the weak nucleophile can come in and
attack that describes an sn1 mechanism
an e1 competes with that secondary
substrates are only about as hindered as
this primary branched example and so
they'll undergo sn2 when treated with a
weak base but the tertiary substrate
cannot do that we can't get backside
attack so even under weakly basic
conditions we have the sn1 and e1
mechanisms competing here again our
strong bases and strong hindered bases
are promoting e2 reactions except when
that mechanism is not available and when
this primary substrate is completely
unhindered with the strong base I hope
this video is helping you start to cope
with all of these competing mechanisms
and start to see that there actually are
general trends based on our substrate
and our nucleophile strengths and
properties in the next video in this
series I'm going to continue this chart
to include a
lilyc and benzylic substrates these are
much more complicated due to resonance
effects and electronic effects through
the Rings so if you'd like to go a
little bit deeper please come back and
see me again
subscribe hit that notification bell and
we'll start to talk about those
substrates next time